bang
bang lunch money time well while she's
trying to get rich the rest of us trying
to get our lunch money
right we back two days off
guess what we went and got married
that's where we were some of you
predicted it
some of you didn't but we went and we
got married we took two days off
don't kill us everybody relax i am here
by the way with the beautiful and
intelligent
paulina marinova pompliano now how about
that so all you guys leaving comments
about polina get out of the comments
she's mine
oh what oh the reason you guys weren't
you're rusty come on speed it up you're
rusty okay can you stop speaking
um the reason you guys weren't invited
is because no one was invited
it was just us oh yeah it was just us
our parents didn't even come
it's all right they'll get over it all
right don't forget
speaking of marriage and love i love
block five
should have had block five uh sponsor
the wedding that'd been pretty cool
i'm shocked you didn't mention them
during the vows yeah i could have
uh block fly's got three products they
allow you to buy and sell crypto you can
deposit
crypto and get a us dollar loan or my
favorite product is you
can go and earn up to 8.6 interest
i'm an investor in the company i am a
very heavy user of the product
if you go and you sign up using the link
in the description before july 18th
which is coming up soon
that's like three days away if you open
an account and fund it
they will give you 2x interest on
your account in august go do it now
should i do it my beautiful bride go
ahead and hit us what's going on with
parking lots
your beautiful bride come on let's go by
the way let's not let's not hold on
timeout tio
you still think that you're uh a bride
because you have on a
white jumpsuit no it's because i'm an
angel
this ain't wedding season it's over
you'll never have another one again
what's going on with the parking lot
let's go
well mall owners are renting out parking
lots during the coveted pandemic
uh because retail real estate owners are
scrambling for solutions what are they
renting them out for
movies virtual concerts etcetera okay
that makes sense but i like it i
appreciate the creativity
in times of constraint is that really
creativity yeah they're getting
smoked i don't think this is creativity
creativity would say yo amazon we got a
warehouse for you
creativity would be like hey we're going
to take that department store we're
going to turn into apartments
creativity would be i'm going to turn my
mall into a mini city i'm going to
recruit people here
creativity is not huh would you like to
pay to park in my parking lot
that's not creativity well they're
trying to at least make some money
the chief marketing officer of
brookfield's retail arm
said uh if we can't rent the mall we're
gonna rent other space
uh we actually have tons of ideas for
our parking lot so maybe they do have
other ideas they're just a little food
market or something out there
where they call it uh farmer's market
farmer's market yeah i'm not sure how
much money that would make off of that
but yeah
all right what's going on with sirius xm
siriusxm is buying stitcher for 325
million dollars
why i know okay
we need to stop recording these after
you've had coffee because you're
extremely annoying
um we're married she can't leave now
the move sets sirius to compete even
more seriously against spotify i heart
media and apple
for dominance in the podcasting space so
do you think everybody saw the joe
brogan
situation no this has nothing to do with
that why because they're buying it
because of three things
one they have a podcast listing or a
publishing platform
two is they've got a entire ad network
uh so they have a a great sales arm
that's able to seriously
send us no stitcher yes stitcher has a
publishing
platform they've got an ad network and
then they have their own proprietary
podcast shows and podcast networks so
they've got content they've got ads and
they've got the publishing
technology infrastructure stack so you
add those three things in
it now immediately gives sirius a foot
in the door or a wedge into the
podcasting space across the three
verticals you need for the business it's
just kind of annoying that's an
analysis for you ain't going to get that
analysis anywhere else
you might get it um it's just kind of
annoying because like
apple apple podcasts are so distributed
that like i'm like oh wait what was that
on again was it
exclusive to spotify apple stitcher like
it takes well it goes against podcasting
like the whole
ethos of podcasting is that it should be
open and free
uh it's like an rss feed like the whole
idea of spotify going and signing up
exclusives
i hate that idea right just from like a
pure ethos standpoint because
what ends up happening is you're taking
something that's free and you're
bringing it to your platform
so the equivalent would be like kind of
this is an equivalent would be like
google's chrome browser saying
no you know what actually your website
we want it exclusive to our
platform people can't use the other
platforms like imagine if that happened
on the web people like wait
what you'd be like i can't open safari
and go to readtheprofile.com
readtheprofile.com
but i have to go on yeah i have to go to
chrome like same thing here right is
that podcasts are supposed to be able to
be
published anywhere it's an open rss feed
and so in that situation
if you start to make it specific to a
certain platform you're basically taking
away a lot of the value
uh the value proposition of podcasts
isn't kind of similar with news and
newsletters and all that no because that
stuff's not open
uh like news should be in my opinion
open it
up but but news in in the structure of
it is not
published in an open format right you
can add it to an rss feed
but it's not default to an rss right
podcasts are default that way
and therefore they're trying to actually
reverse it so we'll see what's going on
with tesla
man elon is having a [ __ ]
six month run he is on fire
okay so lawmakers in texas just gave
tesla
and elon musk another incentive to
locate its next factory there
commissioners in travis county home to
austin in the possible next
tesla factory approved tuesday property
tax breaks
were worth at least 14.7 million dollars
and potentially more over 10 years wow
so okay
i mean total 50 50 million dollars is
what they're using as tax incentives
so 50 million dollars 14 million is the
latest one but they previously gave them
like
45 or 46 million of tax abatements
so it's now 50 million dollars so
explain explain what a tax abatement is
well just
in general the way that this works is a
county says okay
uh if you were to move here you would
pay based on the size how many employees
the amount of money like all of the
factors
you would normally pay us uh 200 million
dollars in taxes over the next 10 years
i'm making those numbers up but you know
200 million dollars and what we're gonna
do is we're gonna make a deal with you
you don't have to pay us 200 million
dollars in taxes now based on all of
these different tax
uh kind of uh grants if you will
they're saying well now you only pays
150 million so basically you're going to
make an additional 50 million dollars by
coming to our city
versus he's looking i think like uh las
vegas or utah or something or oklahoma i
forget where it is
but when you compare it now elon sits
down and he says okay
so one city i'm going to pay 150 million
dollars in taxes
in this other city i'm going to pay x
dollars in taxes so let's say it's 200
million
so i'm literally going to save 25 of my
tax bill by moving to
and putting the plant in austin texas
that's not the only thing he's going to
look at he's also going to look at
talent
right all that type of stuff as well but
it's a big piece of it do we actually
think he's going to move it to texas yes
i i think it'll end up in austin yeah
well because for a couple of different
reasons so uh one there's incredible
technology talent that's flocking to
austin texas
which is a really really big thing two
is uh
the all these tax uh benefits that he
would get three
is he already spends a lot of time in
texas because of spacex they actually do
a lot of uh development there and i
think maybe they do like test launches
as well uh no they've got a site in
texas
um and then the other thing is uh i
actually do think that he's very
anti-california
like i think he's really pissed off uh
at the way that california's handled a
lot of this
and there's something about the uh kind
of
position socially uh that texas has
taken
agree with the disagree with it whatever
if you are uh
into the idea that um they handled the
virus in a different way
and that's the way that you like in
terms of personal freedom individual
liberties all that kind of stuff
then naturally you're going to be uh
drawn to go there because you think
they'll handle other situations in the
future similarly
the virus into this but under the terms
that's what that's what
drove just everyone remembers that's
what kicked all this off
under the terms of the agreement with
travis county though tesla must invest
1.1 billion in the new factory within
the first five years
yeah so like that's the whole key right
they're saying like we need to know your
long term well long term i mean you're
going to build a factory so you're going
to be there for a long time right
because you're literally
but why are they specifying just how
much he needs to invest in the factory
well it's probably broken down not in
this article but in
in terms of like the agreement where
they'll say hey the facility's got to be
ex in size and you've got to employ a
wide number of people there's got to be
you know all this kind of stuff because
what they're doing is they're doing a
calculation right okay if you have a
100 acre facility here's how much taxes
we're going to get right if you would uh
hire this many people at the average
salary of this here's the like
there's all this analysis that goes into
it at the end of the day
it's a culmination of all of the inputs
is what will drive the decision
but i do think you'll end up in austin
so we'll see all right what's going on
with adam newton
is adam newman still hanging adam
newman's hanging
he's making investments adam newman you
might remember the
ex wework ceo who was ousted by softbank
and that whole drama
well since he went back and sued sophinc
this is his first investment that he's
made he has
taken a 33 equity stake in go-to global
a shared mobility company that operates
in israel and malta
it needs to expand into europe later
this year
so that's kind of interesting so they do
electric scooters and mopeds and
bicycles and all that stuff
could he change direction or do you
think this is true
he's definitely gonna go try to do
something else uh
look he's got a family office he's got
like almost a billion dollars after the
whole we worked
well but he sued we are unclear no no
before that billion dollars he's already
got you know at least hundreds of
millions of dollars for sure and he's
supposed to get another billion as
kind of his exit package uh what i find
interesting
is um one he
invested 10 million dollars in a 19
million dollar round he bought 33
ownership in this business and it just
feels like
uh it's a lot of percent well it just
feels like he's kind of like
um taking a big shot like oh this other
thing like
everyone knows me for uh i'm gonna go
and like really kind of throw money
at this other um you know new interest
of mine
investing maybe it works maybe it
doesn't i don't know i don't even know
this company it's not the united states
but uh it's just very very interesting
to see kind of
to come out of the gate with your first
investment stroke in 10 million dollar
checks and buying you know
double digit percentages what kind of
goes us alongside the ethos
of we work right so apparently the
source in this article said that newman
made the investment because he believes
flexibility will be a key component in
people's lives post-coping
uh maybe i don't know what uh
stupid scooters have to do with
flexibility but sure we'll flex it
flexible you know get here
go there you don't want to be inside of
ubers
yeah i guess i don't know i'll take it
can you do me a favor can you look up
166 second street
or second avenue maybe uh in new york
that's the name of
uh his family office is 166 a second
financial something and my guess i don't
know for sure my guess
is that that is a massive wework
building yeah i think it is actually
yeah it is yep
look at that look how funny that is oh
wait so how is it possible
no no that's the name of it so one of
the rules a lot of oh oh there's freak
here's a free uh they said it was
located
here's a free jewel for you guys
in the finance world the reason why so
many people
named their firms after physical places
so
addresses uh places where they grew up
um you know forest and woods and creeks
and rivers and lakes and all
this kind of stuff is because there's no
protection on if you
already use the name right so like i
grew up on let's say
jones street okay if you call it jones
street capital
and then i come in and i name mine jones
street investment
you can't prevent me from using the name
jones street because it's a physical
location
right so that's why people constantly do
that so you'll see them using lakes
rivers
forests um you know uh addresses all
that kind of stuff that's why that
is uh so popular but don't you want to
be kind of unique and not be
jones but there's thousands of
investment firms in the world so like
what's that there's only so many like
patientcapital.com
if we had a family office i know what
the name would be for that what
paulina is the coho is the host of
lunchmoney.com
what's going on with deutsche bank you
definitely will not be naming anything
around here
by the way this wouldn't even be called
lunch money if it wasn't for me if it
was up to you you'd be calling it
something like paulina show
what's up with deutsche bank so deutsche
bank got slammed with 150 million dollar
fine for failing to flag jeffrey
epstein's
shady transactions i'm just gonna say it
this is my personal opinion
deutsche bank is a criminal organization
all right all right it is
how many times how many times do you
have to get
charged with crimes fine it was
different department participating in
all this shady stuff
until because if you weren't a bank and
i did this
or a listener did this you'd be
considered a criminal
so i if the media really covered this
stuff the way it should be covered
literally the way you should write is
criminal
organization deutsche bank instead of
deutsche bank a financial organization
somebody should do like a deep dive
investigation into this but
basically authorities say that deutsche
bank's significant compliance failures
allowed epstein to conduct hundreds of
transactions
totaling millions of dollars that should
have prompted additional scrutiny
and do you think that if it wasn't
epstein they would be more scrutinous
of someone else doing these types of
transactions well there's plenty of
examples
of them going after people where the
banks have done bad things
but again when i i'm i'm half joking but
i'm
i'm
actually more serious than uh than not
in that the banks have a hard job right
everyone's trying to put money through
the banks it's hard to keep track of all
that kind of stuff
but that is why they are regulated the
way they are and so
we have to change the conversation
around
people forget literally there are banks
that are very well known in the united
states
that have been charged with federal
crimes
local crimes individuals who run those
banks have been charged with
they can't just go out of business
because they're like a bank right well
one the government could definitely shut
you down if you did something
absolutely atrocious but but the shut it
all down but the thing is
if if you watch like the local news
right and somebody was charged with a
crime
what they would say is uh let's say
you're uh charged with murder
they would say suspected murder or
murder suspect
pulling a marinova right don't be using
my name but
but when a bank executive is charged
with a crime
nobody writes articles saying potential
fraudster you know bank ceo below
whatever
well they sometimes do yes they do
yes they do i'll give you an example
search jamie diamond's name on the
internet
jamie dimon's been charged with crimes
why does every article start with jp
morgan chase ceo jamie dimon what is
this
ceo but why doesn't it start with of
course though but why doesn't it start
with the criminal
charges because again
white collar crime is treated
differently in society
than blue-collar crime so in this
situation deutsche bank is getting
charged they're going to be fair i think
killing a human being is a little
different than doing some
shady white collar stuff which you could
argue has killed
people via they killed more people
via um like drugs and
legal drugs yeah but like a great
example is if uh on netflix there's a
show
called dirty money and if you go and you
watch i forget which bank it is so i'm
not gonna
speculate on it but one of them worked
with uh the cartels
and the cartels were funneling money
through the bank and basically the bank
just turned a blind eye right they
didn't want to know where the money was
coming from
but are you telling me that financing a
cartel is worse
than a guy who goes out on the street
and shoots somebody one time
who's who who's the bigger criminal does
the cartel
kill people of course that's their whole
business basically
but also the other thing is uh epstein
uh gallane maxwell's i say her name
galen glenn maxwell these people are not
good people
obviously uh and what's gonna end up
happening here is we're gonna have to
unpack
who helped them right who helped them
because obviously they didn't do this
just as in as individuals there were
institutions and people who helped them
uh do this behavior glenn maxwell was
arrested in new hampshire
on a uh in a house on 150 acres of land
that she recently bought i think last
year
and when she bought it she bought in all
cash it's like a two million dollar home
right so how does she have access to so
much cash and doing a real estate
transaction
so hold on let's let's back up a minute
so galen maxwell uh it was
uh jeffrey epstein's that was a good
backup
epstein's uh they call her a legend
perverted cohort basically she helped
him recruit
girls and she was part of that whole
network and it wasn't good
um so now she got arrested uh
she got pulled out of her mansion and
also i read an article that said when
authorities knocked on the door of the
new hampshire
mansion she ran to another room like
that would have helped
anyway so she is asking
she is asking to be allowed to stay in a
luxury new york city hotel
instead of a federal lock-up until her
trial well it was denied already
it was denied i think yet she she asked
for five million dollars bond
they denied it uh because they say she's
such a big flight rate
she's a flight risk yeah they basically
they're just like look she's too well
connected she's got
multiple citizenships around the world
she's got too much cash like
she just she'll leave um and what i
found that was absolutely nuts
is uh jeffrey epstein had asked for
a hundred million dollars bond he was
denied she asked for five million she's
denied and then she said oh by the way
fine i'll stay like a luxury hotel in
new york
uh denied but what is a a
i think a real situation is that people
are scared
of being in charge of protecting her
right so if you're sitting there and
you're a part of the prison
uh system you're like look i got this
woman here who
by the way her cohort was killed right
or committed suicide uh allegedly
um and so now i'm in charge of her how
do i protect her
and so i've read articles where they're
literally moving her from cell to cell
multiple times a day to try to prevent
someone being able to plan how to
actually get to her
and they not only have to protect her
from external things right
so uh a dirty uh prison guard
somebody visiting the facility somebody
breaking into the facility all that kind
of stuff but then they also have to
protect it from the other prison
population
because this would put somebody somebody
would become infamous in the prison
culture
if they were the one who took her out
and so you just get in this weird
situation where like well
do we even want to be in charge of
actually having her at our prison
because it causes all this other chaos
yeah i can't imagine
uh by the way it took criminology in
college and i the one thing i remember
is that um prisoners for other prisoners
do not like sexual predators rapists
people like that and she is connected to
the biggest like pedophile
ever so um she's connected
but i don't understand why people don't
call her
a pedophile i don't allegedly
yeah we don't know anyway so um but
there is you know some evidence to
suggest she was
very very closely involved with the
whole thing
but um no don't be looking at my jokes
what are you doing you crazy
okay uh so anyway galene
can i just ask how you can just ask a
judge to put you up in a nice
luxury city can i ask for that you can
do whatever you want like right now can
i be like can you put me
up no no but she probably offered to pay
for it herself oh i see she said look on
my time if you allow me to i'll go stay
in this hotel you can put security there
but
whatever all right what's your joke
let's go we're in out of time my joke
is it doesn't matter how often a married
man
changes his job he still ends up with
the same boss
it's funny it's so funny
oh that's not a joke because it's true
[Laughter]
all right guys we're super excited we
got married we're back
she's got the rust off i'm always on top
of my game that's it for lunch one day
today
but while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us she's trying to get her lunch
money right we'll see you tomorrow
i'm wearing white and you're wearing
black yeah you're out of uniform
no see you bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account go do your own research
there's risk associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends